He just measures, which is shown by these gray boxes. To measure in the X basis, he first applies a hatamard and
then he measures. We'll run this circuit using the Qiskit runtime primitive sampler. And the output is Bob's bit
string of measurements. Then we can compare Bob's bitst strings to Alice's initial bit string throwing out the bits
where their bases didn't match. And we see that they both get the same key.
Remember this is real hardware so there occasionally might be a bit that should match but doesn't. In this case all the
bits match but if you run this again on your own you could get an error but as long as the fidelity is close to one
Alice and Bob can be reasonably sure that there was no eavesdropper. Now let's see what happens if Eve intercepts the
cubits. Now we have two circuits. The first shows Alice's preparation and Eve's interception and
measurement. The next shows Eve's preparation of the spoof cubits and Bob's measurement. We
can run these circuits as before, then see what Alice and Bob would get when they compare their bitst
strings. This time they get a fidelity of 6 repeating. This is way lower than
can be explained by noise on the quantum computer. So they conclude that Eve was eavesdropping. Quantum computing is
wellknown and often hyped for its potential to solve hard problems. But quantum communication and cryptography
often get much less attention even though the potential that quantum can offer in these areas is equally
significant and exciting. Today we discuss the earliest discovered protocol for quantum key distribution which is
practically immune to undetected eavesdropping. If you want to try your hand at sending an unbreakable code with
a quantum certified key, head over to the module linked in the description.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you next time.